a lot of lenders have withdrawn their
products from the market the government
can't afford for the property Mark to go
off the board the average two-year
mortgage rate up to six percent
everyone's freaking out like it's the
end of the world we're encouraging buy
to let now know to act now jeez so all
the people all interest rates are going
to go up they should have been buying
the bank of England have raised interest
rates to the highest level since 2008.
we've already seen some landlords
looking at their portfolio and selling
them we know that whenever there's a
crisis there's always opportunities to
make money think of people who bought
properties 20 years ago and then
suddenly the slump came and they found
it was in negative equity it's double in
price now what do you think is going to
happen with interest rates over the next
six 12 months
welcome back to my channel I'm sat here
with Andrew Clothier from Regents Court
Financial he is a mortgage broker
Finance expert and we're going to be
talking all about interest rates what
the heck is happening right now with
mortgage rates and mortgage lenders
withdrawing their products from the
market what's happening can you still
get a mortgage is property investing
dead is it still viable and um Andrew I
really appreciate you coming all the way
from Wolverhampton no problem so firstly
what is happening with mortgages before
the the big problem that corrupt up two
or three weeks ago several mortgage
lenders had closed their door to new
business only so that they could get
through their pipeline because they were
inundated with work yeah but then as
soon as it hit us a couple of weeks ago
then a lot of other lenders followed
suit not only to clear their pipeline
but to work out over the passage of Time
how much they would in future charge
people for a mortgage so what's the
reason that a lot of lenders have
withdrawn their products from the market
are they coming back and when this stuff
started to drift back now one or two so
they will gradually all of them drift
back over the passage of Time how
quickly we don't know but it's not fair
to say you can't get a mortgage at the
moment you can get a mortgage but the
number of lenders you have to choose
from is quite severely restricted right
so if you don't have to get a mortgage
now if you if you if you can wait a
little then it's a good idea to keep an
eye on what's going on so you can see
gradually as more and more lenders open
their doors and we predicted this would
happen yes I mean we've done interviews
before yes we predicted this would
happen interest rates have historically
been extremely low yes the fact that
they've gone up a little bit everyone's
freaking out like it's the end of the
world it's really not I mean we were
talking earlier about how the banks even
stress measured this yes talk to me
about that yes and buy to let mortgages
for quite a few years now when somebody
wants a buy to let mortgage ifs for
example they want to borrow a hundred
thousand pounds they usually have an
interest-only mortgage so before the
bank grants the mortgage they stress
test the rent against the interest
payment and the and the interest payment
they use generally was 5.5 percent right
which is close to what we are right now
it is so in other words when people were
only paying 1.5 for an interest only a
buy to let mortgage that the case was
being stress tested at 5.5 which seemed
severe in some cases but if you think
about it it works well for the borrower
as well because not only does it prepare
them for the event that interest rates
get to five and a half percent it also
tells them whether or not the buy to let
is a good Prospect in other words if it
doesn't get anywhere near the 5.5
percent threshold then it may be a
signal to the buyer that perhaps they
shouldn't be buying this because there's
not enough in it for them the gap
between the rent and the mortgage
payment what do you think is going to
happen with interest rates over the next
six 12 months I honestly think that
interest rates will probably continue to
rise to some extent everybody's getting
excited about next week when the bank of
England make their announcement again
and all the media are forecasting that
the rate will go up again at some stage
you and I know that it will have to
settle back because it'll stop people
buying properties yeah and the
government can't afford for the property
Market to go off the boil too much
they've got to keep the market as
balanced as they can they're going out
well I mean I've been in the game for a
long time not as long as yourself I mean
you're now how old 73 73 yes but I mean
you know we you've been through the the
80s where rates were at one point just
close to 15 right yes yes I've been
through at least two recessions and we
know that whenever there's a crisis or
whenever there's a big change actually
there's always opportunities there
there's always opportunities to make
money there's always opportunities to
profit off of adapt and profit off of
the off of the crisis off of the change
yes I mean there's no question that for
some time the mortgage lenders have
thought that the value of properties
will will go down because you've had a
tremendous boom this year haven't we
with people being gazumped and yeah and
prices pushed up lenders have all
thought for some time that that won't be
sustained and they're right we can't
sustain that level of increase it will
ultimately level out and then it will
probably shrink back a little bit for a
good year now mortgage lenders valuers
have have been often undervaluing the
properties less than the purchase price
so if you've agreed to buy somewhere for
a hundred thousand it's been quite
common for the valued at 95 or 90 90
000. yeah that is a marker that the
lenders themselves have forecasted that
there's going to be a what they call a
correction right and there's a big
difference as well Andrew between a
property crash and a property correction
or a property dip yes you know people
are talking on on YouTube I see all the
time saying and they've been saying it
for years there's going to be a crash
there's going to be a crash properties
always go up and then they dip and then
they go up and then they dip and that's
that's the way the market Works in my
experience politicians have always said
if we get into Power we'll stop this
boom and bust in the property market and
I always say how they're going to do
that
that would take quite a bit of doing
yeah and so I I don't think there's
going to be much uh movement in the
property Market in in the immediate
future
um I think they'll be leveling out years
ago we didn't have the buy to let Market
the first buy select mortgage I did was
in 1997 with Skipton Building Society
they were the first lenders to come out
with vitalets other lenders said oh no
not quite a lead so up to that time
first time buyers drove the property
Market if you couldn't get first-time
buyers to buy houses because they were
priced out of the market you had no
property Market since then first-time
buyers are generally in competition with
the buyer letters so that has meant that
the the market has always been a little
bit more buoyant than it would have been
if we didn't have the buy toilets
interesting another thing as well that I
see at the moment is with interest rates
going up and with property prices
potentially dipping I think that's going
to lead to quite a lot of landlords
being in negative equity yes we've
already seen some landlords looking at
their portfolio identifying some of the
weak spots and selling them and I think
there'd be more of that the other thing
that's coming up which a lot of
landlords I speak to don't seem to
understand is that the EPC certificate
that you have on your property after
2025
if you rent your house out to somebody
it'll have to be at least an a b or c
EPC certificate that's April 2025 I
believe yes that's right so it's not far
off no it's not and what will actually
happen if we're not careful is a
landlord will approach somebody like us
and say in in April or May 2025 oh I've
got a portfolio of properties that are
all below a sea can you remortgage them
please so that I can produce some cash
to to insulate them and bring them in
line and will the lenders remortgage a
property after that time that is not an
a b or c or will they say no get it up
to scratch and then we'll give you the
money so we we're encouraging buy to let
portfolio landlords to act now yeah
um rather than wait till the last minute
well one of the things that we've seen
being opportunistic in in our business
is we've we've been securing more lease
option agreements than ever before yes
because there's landlords that are
wanting to sell some of them have are
financed up to the health yes so we can
say look we'll buy your property off
here you want to get rid of it you
worried about EPC and you're worried
about we'll take the property off you
and then we'll buy it off you in seven
years and then we're taking over their
mortgage payments but of course then
we're using our strategies with mortgage
consent of course like service
accommodation hmos room lets getting a
nice cash flow from the property and
then we're getting the option to buy it
as you say um whatever happens in the
market there are opportunities for
people what about the media because the
media are absolute Scoundrels in my
opinion in terms of continually scare
mongering
continually publishing sensationalist
stories just for views and information
is not even true and I've seen so much
stuff about it even on the TV and in the
newspapers about mortgages about
interest rates that frankly I wish that
you'd been there in the room to argue
because I mean there was one lady saying
oh my lender has just pulled out and now
saying that I have to pay 10 and this
that and the other one I'm thinking that
doesn't make any sense no no the media
are bound to to pick on the interesting
looking cases the main misconception
people have is that if they already have
a mortgage offer so if the lender has
issued them with a mortgage offer and
they're just waiting for the legal work
to complete the the the deal it's very
unlikely that the mortgage lender will
will either increase the interest rate
or remove the mortgage offer it's
possible but it's unlikely and we
haven't seen it and in fact I noticed
that Leeds billing Society have emailed
lots of their people lots of their
customers who have a mortgage offer at
the moment and are waiting for it to
complete waiting to buy the house or to
remortgage it and they send them a very
nice email saying just so that you
understand we have no intention of
removing the terms we've issued to you
even though interest rates have gone up
as long as you're complete on the
mortgage within the time constraints of
the mortgage offer then we're not going
to withdraw and I think I haven't seen
one to withdraw it and I think it's
unlikely it's going to happen we were
working awfully hard on my portfolio in
the last year or so right yes yes and
I've managed to get millions of pounds
of Finance all fixed yes on ridiculously
low rate I mean my personal house which
is a bit different I think it's about
1.8 percent yes yes which is crazy two
million pound mortgage wouldn't you
could sell that that mortgage on eBay
but then also my my whole portfolio and
my my buy to let I mean you've and I
don't want you to get into trouble I'll
have everyone bombard you because I know
I did this a couple months ago but um
why don't we fix them at like 3.3 yes
yes for five years yes yes and you've
been able to fix rates for on some
mortgages 10 years yes we've got one man
who buys buy to lets and if possible he
always asks us for a 10-year fix and
what has he been paying for that like
five or six percent not as much as that
no what's he been paying three points
something or maybe four percent geez so
all the people right a year ago that
were saying oh interest rates are going
to go up I'm not going to buy
because I'm scared they should have been
buying and fixing I'm a firm believer
that that if you keep putting off buying
a property because you're not earning
enough or you haven't got a big enough
deposit you may not end up getting a
good Advantage
um and if you buy a property if you
intend to keep it if it does reduce in
value slightly as long as you're not
selling it you haven't lost anything
right and think of people who bought
properties 20 years ago and then
suddenly the slump came and they found
it was in negative equity it's double in
price now exactly you've got to get into
property for the long game you can't be
thinking about the next three months
definitely and what are prices going to
do in six months what are interest rates
you've got to think long term yes talk
to me a bit about what people are doing
at the moment that haven't got money
that I wanted to buy properties one of
the things that we've noticed recently
people are doing especially younger
people
um
their parents often will step in to help
them either by gifting them a deposit
or if the parents haven't got it quite a
few of them have been remortgaging their
houses even if they're too old to get a
conventional mortgage so people over 55
can have what's called an equity release
mortgage and that's where they're not
tested to see if they can afford any
repayments because they don't have to
make a repayment it's called a lifetime
mortgage and the idea is that unlike
most conventional mortgages where you
have to make a mortgage payment every
month and you have to specify the end
date you don't have to make a mortgage
payment it's voluntary and the end date
is not to a fixed term it's to when you
if if you're married you and your
partner either die and the property
becomes empty or if you go into a home
so how do you qualify for this so if
you're over 55 yes because most people
that are over 55 start thinking I'm not
going to get a mortgage because I'm not
earn enough I'm not qualified but you're
saying that that's not necessarily the
case and no I mean we do plenty of these
where there's no requirement for them to
make any payments of Interest or capital
so the lender doesn't assess their of
their ability to make any payments
because the lender knows that if they
can't afford to make any payments the
interest just gets added on to the
mortgage every year until the property
becomes empty and how much can they
normally pull out so let's say you've
got a property that's worth three
hundred thousand pounds and it's got no
mortgage on it how much would they be
able to release it's entirely based on
their age it's a bit morbid so if
they're only 55 and they're female they
might only be able to get 25 percent of
the value of the property out so it's
based on morbidity so in other words
what the lender does is they look at the
age and the state of health and the
gender of the person now yeah and they
work out how long the mortgage is like
to be outstanding if you're 80 the
chances are it's not going to be
outstanding for more than about 20 years
if you're 55 it could be outstanding for
many years so the interest if you're 55
would add up a lot why don't more people
know about this because so many people
say to me oh I'm I'm 67. I've got a
house I own it outright but there's no
way I'm going to be able to refinance it
because of my age I think a reason why a
lot of people don't know about it is
they have heard of it but years ago this
type of mortgage was very inflexible and
had a bad reputation so so many people I
meet who asked me for one of these say
well I'd like to talk about it but I've
heard from everybody don't touch them
they're bad news well that might have
been the case 20 or 30 years ago but now
there are lots of hybrid cases and
they're so popular that lenders are very
flexible and offer a very flexible
approach people sometimes
lose so much money because they just
don't know they're able to do something
no it's quite true because I I've got a
couple at the moment and they've got two
daughters and their daughters want to
get in the property market so they're
refinancing their house and giving the
daughters 80 000 each and the children
daughters are buying houses now rather
than if the parents live another 10 20
years you know the daughters don't have
to rent for that period and ultimately
when it comes to interest rates because
now what are you talking right now if
you were to get a buy to let property
interest rates I know it would depend on
different factors yes but it was a year
or two ago I used to say around three
percent yes now what are we talking more
like maybe four to five four and a half
closer to five so a decent rate now what
someone should be happy with will be
about four and a half to five they're
fabulous yeah if they get that that
would be a good rate some people are
getting those on on the existing
mortgage they have being transferred to
a new scheme so we did a couple of
yesterday where they were paying I think
4.3 or 4 0.4 but that's not a new
mortgage that's that's where your
existing mortgage scheme ends and we go
back to the existing lender and say okay
they want to stay with you say for
another two or three or five years what
can you offer them yeah and that's
called a product transfer there is
another solution that we're working with
some people on if I may mention
um to the high fixed rates of Interest
it doesn't suit everybody but we've done
a couple in the last few days where the
interest rate is lower than four percent
sometimes as low as early threes 3.2 3.5
their tracker rates which everybody
throws up their arms and are oh in other
words it's tracking the bank of England
base rate so if the bank of England base
rate Rises your mortgage payment Rises
but there are no early repayment charges
with them
right so if you're somebody who says
well okay if I have a Tracker rate at
3.5 instead of paying 5.5 fixed that's a
two percent reduction in what I would be
paying do I think the bank rate will
continue to rise by another two percent
we don't know do we
but it's a bit of speculation but if it
does continue to rise you can get out of
it because there's no early repayment
charges so how much would your interest
rates be then on a Tracker right now
what we did on Friday for somebody was
an existing client having a new a new
mortgage deal with the same lender that
was 30 percent three percent on a
Tracker rate they paid a 995 fee for it
that's peanuts so they're paying three
percent that's less than me I know it's
not the best but but still that as you
say that that that probably is the thing
to do right if the the media are right
that in in November interest rates will
rise again then you refinance and
there's and there's no early early
repayment fees not everybody wants those
some people are balancing and saying I'm
more comfortable to know that I'm fixed
and I understand that yeah but some
people are saying well as long as I
don't have any early repayment charges I
can always change it I can change it now
some trackers come with early repayment
charges so that's a different kettle of
fish yeah Andrew so many people used to
come to me all the time and I used to
say I've got a right to buy yeah on my
house it's a council house whatever
whatever it's worth 500 Grand I can buy
it for 300 Grand but they didn't think
they could buy it Andrew because they
didn't have the deposit no but then you
came along in your Shining Armor and
helped all these folks out and I want to
give you credit for that because there's
been so many people I'm sure you've been
bombarded with calls that have now
bought their house how have you been
doing that and how does it work well the
first thing to say is this
um the market value you said was 500
they can get it for 300. so so they're
getting 200 000 pounds uh discount right
so they're buying a house worth 500 000
for 300 000. most lenders who do right
to buy mortgages will say you don't need
to put a deposit down because you've got
the difference between the 300 and the
500 market value as your deposit so what
do you do not right to buy just
generally speaking if you want to buy a
house maybe you want to live in it maybe
you want to buy it and rent it out but
you really want to buy a house you've
got the deposit yes but you can't get a
mortgage because maybe you've got bad
credit or maybe you don't earn enough
money or for whatever reason no lender
will touch you with a barge poll if it's
because you don't earn enough money you
can introduce a guarantor to the
prospect or you could have somebody join
you on the mortgage as a joint borrower
if their income is sufficient but they
if they join you on the mortgage they
don't own the home else you've got two
options you they can own the house and
if they do you can agree with them what
share of the house they are one percent
right that's fine
um of course they need to understand and
we would always explain to them if you
have a joint Mortgage in this country
never mind who owns what percentage of
the property each borough is responsible
for 100 of the mortgage so because you
only own one percent of the property it
doesn't mean you're only responsible for
one percent mortgage so you need to get
somebody on that was basically doing you
a favor yes and and understood that look
I'm only getting you on this house or on
this mortgage because I can't do it
myself so it needs to be a friend it
would need to be a relative yeah or a
parent or someone that was doing it and
that's what my stepdad did for me right
well quite often when we do that the
person we have a two-year fixed or
something because the person who needs
the help from somebody else because
their income isn't enough knows that
within that two-year period their income
will have risen sufficiently because
they've become qualified or something
else yeah for us to say to the Joint
borrower thanks for your help we can do
it on our own now and then we release
the joint borrower from their
undertaking so they might only be on for
a few years before they can be removed
and that's why I love doing lease option
agreements so much and I did that as you
know when I when I got started because
we've we've known each other now for
what 14 15 years something like that yes
I was I was a kid bro and we met at
business networking International yes
that's right back in Wolverhampton but
like with a lease option agreement which
is what I did a lot of when I was
teenager would be a case of I'll buy the
house in seven years in the meantime the
mortgage isn't stays in their name I'm
I'm reimbursing them yes but they're in
seven years my credit's better I've
rented the house out and I've saved up
the rent so I've got the deposit there
is another way uh it's more with
residential than buy to let mortgages
yeah and that's where you can have more
than one borrower for example you could
perhaps have four borrowers so you have
four incomes to bring to the table but
perhaps only two of those people own the
property the other two
um are just mortgage borrowers so some
lenders will do that for people there's
always a solution yes and I think that's
what makes you such a great mortgage
broker is that you are solution based
yes and a lot I don't know Andrew a lot
of property professionals they always
find the problem if somebody says what
they want to do we tell them how they do
it even if it looks as if they're they
have no income or we can tell them how
to get through talk to me then about how
do you sort your credit file out how do
you even know what your credit is and
how do you clean it up there's lots of
Credit Agencies Experian clear score
Equifax and we all have a right to sign
up to one of those organizations so that
we can actually view Our Own Credit file
if we want to we recommend people always
subscribe to that to keep an eye on it
not just so that they know what the the
lender is saying about them but also in
case somebody else is is fraudulently
using their name to obtain credit and it
happens a lot and if your credit is bad
because I've even been on there and I
thought oh my gosh that team involved
payment of 20 pounds didn't go through
six months ago and now my it's brought
my credit down how do you how do you
clean that up how do you grow your
credit over time it's a great healing
process for your credit file is time
unfortunately yeah so some lenders say
if you've missed a mortgage payment in
the last few months you can't get a
mortgage but if you missed one last year
or the year before so in other words the
greater the elapse of time from the time
that the event occurs to the time that
you apply for a mortgage is the healing
price so basically pay your bills on
time yes if you've got debts always make
sure you're paying the interest yes talk
to me about multi-lets because you know
me we've always wanted to rent the rooms
out in the house yes and there's a
difference isn't there between like a
proper HMO where you're going to get a
HMO mortgage where you might have like
six or seven rooms on Suites and then if
you just wanting to get consent to rent
out three or four rooms but talk to me
about the different mortgage products
for this if it's an HMO it's has a
license and it has a license because it
requires one because of the number of
properties and that's if there's five or
more people if you want to mortgage and
it's already got a license and that's
fine because the lenders sees what
they're getting
if however it's your intention to buy it
and make it into a five bedroomed HMO
then the lender will still assess it as
an HMO and still charge an interest rate
based on HMO but some of them will say
right before we mortgage it we've got to
see that you have actually made your
application to the local Authority for
the license however if it's less than
five and it's a multi-layered in other
words it doesn't need an HMO license
then there's two ways A lender can treat
it most of them just say well we'll
regarded as an HMO it's the same thing
because you're renting individual rooms
you're not having one AST you're having
a group of asts however can you imagine
perhaps a student that
where there's three or four students in
there and they all sign the same AST
there's only one AST there aren't three
or four ASD Amazon some lenders say um
depending upon what our valuer says we
might regard that as a single AST
mortgage what about if you're doing it
as a service accommodation and you're
renting it out on Airbnb or short stay
let's there's two types nowadays that
the lenders will deal with they'll
either call them a holiday let or or a
service accommodation and quite a lot of
the ones that we do are actually holiday
accommodation holiday let's basically so
again there are lenders who do those
whether it's you buy it as a private
individual or limited company there are
lenders who do those but they charge a
higher rate of interest why is it
important to get the right type of
mortgage on the right type on this on
the house so what would happen if you
rented a property out
on Airbnb but you just had a buy to let
mortgage or a Residential Mortgage let's
say you bought it on a Residential
Mortgage and you put down a small
deposit of 10 yeah you had really cheap
rates and then you've rented it out on
Airbnb what could be the consequence of
that people do it the potential hazards
are that your mortgage lender finds out
sometime somehow if the mortgage lender
finds out they will say to you wait a
minute we didn't authorize this uh for
you to use this in this way if it's a
residential if it's a lender who doesn't
do buy to let they're going to insist
that you pay the mortgage off and that
will mean you'd have to remortgage and
they might then Blacklist you and not
lend to you again I've heard of that but
I I haven't seen it happen one thing you
have to do is you have to make sure if
you change it from residential or single
then so you have to make sure that your
insurance company is informed right
because if they're not and there's a
problem and there's a fire or something
you could find that you have no covering
Force another thing is as you know one
of the things that we do regularly is
we'll buy a house on on a bridge yep and
then once we've refurbed it we'll then
refinance this yes and get our money
back yes is that something that you you
guys help with I know you do all the
time a couple of things
um some lenders will not refinance a
house in fact probably more than 50 of
lenders will not refinance a house until
you've owned it for six months yeah but
that's that's standard though because
the refurb is going to take you a good
few months but people don't realize
Andrew that there's any lenders that
will let you do it sooner than that they
will let you do it but the thing you've
got to watch is supposing you bought
this property run down for a hundred
thousand yeah and after after two months
you you've made it much better you've
improved it dramatically so it's now
worth 120 130 000. some lenders who will
refinance it within six months will will
only evaluate at what you paid for it
even though it's worth more money there
wasn't value it at full Market Fair you
might persuade them if you show them
what you've done there you might
persuade them to tweak it up a little
bit yeah but you won't generally get the
full number so generally you have to
expect to wait six months I think so
because then you've got the full
spectrum of lenders six months is not a
long time to write no and on a bridge
your interest will be very minor so
you'll buy it you'll refurb it you'll
refinance it after six months yes you'll
get your funds back yes and then you're
left with effectively a free house yes
which is an incredible strategy we find
commonly people don't allow enough time
on the bridging loan correct uh because
they say oh it's going to take me three
months to uh improve it then the
bridging loan finishes in six months
right but you can't refi you can't make
the application for the refunds until
you've owned it for six months yeah and
then the bridging loans expired it's
going to take another month or two at
least to get them all have the situation
with a couple on our Academy they've
just negotiated to buy a house yes they
need to get planning permission to turn
into flat then turn it into Flats all
the building control that goes with that
at the whole caboodle and they got a
bridge for 12 months and I said it's a
big project planning permission alone
could take six and then by the time
you've got all the builders and building
control you know you you are risk asking
cutting it too fine so I think that's
the importance of having good
professional advisors so Andrew thank
you very much for your time thank you
very much thank you all the best